Okay,
we're alive.
Wish I would remember the category.
So, little something different today.
Um,
every so often we kind of just need
something timely for a client. And um,
sometimes that is something that's very
closely tied to a project that I can't
really talk about.
But sometimes it's just ends up being um
a piece of sort of general research that
just needs to be rush ordered is what we
have at the moment going on.
So I have to mess around with some
kernels. Um this is mostly codec crap,
but
I think we can probably
get somewhere with this.
Presumably, this can be made
substantially faster than the uh the
torch version. We will see.
Hey,
welcome. Long time no see.
Hope you're doing well.
I suppose I've seen you in the uh the
Discord more.
Currently, I need to take a couple hours
today. Today is a short stream day, but
I have just like a oneoff task. the
custom encoder that we did a little bit
of research on. Um, we now need this for
a client project. So, I need to like
test this, get this integrated, etc.,
etc.
This is
fairly straightforward, I'd say.
Um, there are a few possible points
where things are a little questionable,
but actually, here's what we'll do.
We'll make this fun.
Instead of me just being boring for yet
another day in a row, I will um I'll
kind of draw out what I'm doing.
Well, uh because otherwise we just have
to wait for this stupid
stupid codeex loop.
All right, so this is how it works,
right? You have some entities. Let's say
that you have, you know, a screen. I
think the task we have is like targets.
And then there's like fish.
That's not how you draw a fish at all,
is it?
How do you draw the fish like this?
Right.
Yeah. So you have fish and you have
targets, right? So there lots of fish
or lots of targets. These are all
entities. The observations for these,
right? This is going to be like X Y.
But it also can see
all these which have their own like X Y
positions.
And one thing you could do
so like flat
is you just concatenate everything. So
you just get like x
x
like obviously with subscripts, right?
But you can also do this type of cool
pointwise
16 dim
and then
eight max.
So 16 dim hidden layer with a reu and
then 128 dim layer with a max. And the
key is that this operation
fused kernel
super slow operation without a fused
kernel. But the insight is that each of
these intermediates doesn't need to be
very big. The output needs to be big.
But as long as you have several
intermediates here, you can project
these to the output de and fuse the max.
That's the architecture. We already have
this uh validated. We have a very clean
experiment on this in torch. Now we're
going to see if we can get this into
CUDA and fast
entity encoder address.
We uh it turns out we need
Yep, we have a big client project at the
moment.
It's kind of cool though the way that
Puffer works, right? like we kind of
have all this cutting edge research and
um it's sort of like we have our own
agenda for what needs to be prioritized
but then when companies hire us for
stuff we kind of just shift stuff around
um in order to make stuff ready in the
order that the client needs it.
That's one of the big perks of working
with us.
Are you batching? So you don't need to
batch the relu. Um yes we are going to
fuse this probably but it this doesn't
matter. This operation is fast because
this is uh points to dim 16. This is
very low compute very low memory
pressure.
This operation from 16 to 128 is low
compute but high memory pressure
without fusing the max. So this whole op
very few flops but very high memory
pressure if you don't fuse this thing at
the end.
Love for community is fun.
There's so much cool stuff in the works
at the moment.
Only thing that's a little bit annoying
is I really don't like this codeex
bullshitting workflow and I end up
working far fewer hours when I have to
do this type of stuff versus like, you
know, doing some real
but that's fine.
Now, so the key thing to understand
here, right, it's so the architecture
looks like this.
So it's like a very small input, right?
A very small intermediate
and then a big output,
right?
So this here this is high me pressure
because you materialize for every
embedding for every single entity right
so number of entities times number of
observations times 128 you materialize a
huge amount of data and this is how
torch does it like this is basically how
you have to do it if you're just using
your normal torch net but because this
is actually going to get max.
It's going to just be some minor
incremental update. If they didn't
change the if they didn't change the
version number, I guarantee you I
wouldn't notice.
Why use codeex then versus handcrafted
real end?
So a few reasons. One, this is not like
this project doesn't get a clean slate.
Okay. Um puffer is now basically pure
cudac. Um, but it sort of inherited crap
from torch and we are cutting that bit
by bit. Um, in fact in Puffer 5 there
will finally be no more Python, no more
Torch at all. But because of that, like
there's still a bunch of bloat and
things that had to match existing
implementations such that it's kind of
tricky to handedit until we get it cut
down a little bit more, which aside from
today, that's what I've been streaming
the last few days is trying to refactor
it down into a more manageable shape.
The second reason is, frankly, I'm just
somewhat new to CUDA still. Uh, I've
been doing low-level for a few years and
of course I've been doing RL for a
decade, but I'm relatively new to CUDA
and while I do understand what's going
on here, um, at the syntax level, I
would be quite slow with this stuff.
And, um, especially for things like this
where this is essentially a standard
tiled matmo application. Uh, this is a
standard tiled maple that is fused with
just an activation. like this thing has
a billion instances of this in the
training data. And in fact, in a more
reasonable world, instead of having
sight highle libraries like torch, we
would just have nice clean kernels for
all these operations that you could just
grab and paste into your project. We
unfortunately don't live in that world.
So, it's very very slow um to do this
stuff by hand. Yeah, I guess it's just a
combination of like
it's a combination of having inherited
stuff from old like other projects, but
also just the type of thing we're doing
being obviously a very reasonable thing,
but they're just not being resources or
references whatsoever in this area.
CPU, MPS, etc. drop in Puffer 5. Um,
so in Puffer 5, no, so CPU actually is
going to have better eval support than
ever. Eval support. Um, in fact, there's
a single standalone C file that will
just work with everything. Super easy to
understand. Um, really portable. You can
run it on anything. Torch CPU will be
dropped though cuz we're not going to do
that. I might might still have a
reference torch implementation. I'm not
sure yet. We're going to see on that. I
might still do that. But I think for the
main architecture, like the main what we
want to support, it's going to be really
good GPU training. Very simple CPU
evalu.
Frankly, I don't think it's worth
maintaining that [ __ ] Um I could be
swayed, but it would have to be really
something good.
Soon we'll live in that. Yeah, exactly.
like we're making we're making strides
towards it, right? We're getting to a
place where we have just sane
implementations of all this stuff we
need. It's just very difficult, right?
Nobody does stuff this way at all.
And it shows because like this is not
that much code. I mean, if you were to
think about making a field a thousandx
faster, you would think that that would
take just massive massive amounts of
engineering. And it's taken me a lot of
time and contributors a lot of time, but
that's like a small handful of people
for a couple years. And it's only 13k
lines of code. Actually, quite a bit
less if you cut out some of the
visualization software.
100 mil updates.
Yes, torch is just not written for
networks below a certain uh a certain
size
like
I don't know the make everything simple
by abstracting away the details. It's
just like Python cancer.
I'm very I'm going to be very very happy
to get rid of Python from my workflow
finally.
It's just so bad. It really is.
No, I'm never really excited for the
model launches. It's just like whatever.
Small incremental update.
I missed some stuff. Um I didn't see
your term agent uh a lock. Like good job
on that though. Like you should be uh
you should basically just be doing tons
of projects while you're learning. I do
strongly recommend though that if you've
been doing um
if you've been doing uh highle dev just
yeah get some lowlevel in.
Yeah, I saw I there were a bunch of
people talking at the same time. So
just read I actually I think you should
reread my programming guide like every
couple months because it's one of those
resources where all the information that
you need it truly is there. It's just
you're not going to be able to
appreciate everything that's there until
you're much more experienced. But every
couple months, like if you come back to
it, you'll pick up something new.
Um
I the one of the very nice things with
lowlevel, frankly,
if you're like doing a standalone end or
something like that, C really doesn't
have that much syntax. It's very very
light on the amount of crap to remember.
You just need to know some basic
fundamentals and you can build a lot
with it.
There's some exceptions like string
processing is a pain in the ass, right?
But for like just most logic heavy
applications, it's really easy.
I'd argue easier than Python
because the thing is Python's a really
big language, right? There's a huge
standard library with a bunch of stuff
in it.
Um physical application it depends on
clients entirely.
I mean, if a drone company calls me up
tomorrow and wants a big contract,
right, then it'll be drones.
Definitely not physical Atari.
That is,
man, I can appreciate the engine, the
research that goes into that stuff, but
like that problem setup that they have
is just it was literally a joke at
OpenAI when I was there that somebody
was going to do it that way. Like that
was literally a common joke. It's they
kind of did the meme
and even like physical applications we
do will not be let's learn from a single
stream of data in real time. It will be
let's simulate a millennia of data with
lots of randomization and then transfer
it.
The Cbook is a nice reference, but like
you really need to build Enough.
Hey, we're open to contracts if you have
um RSM problems.
We have a little bit of capacity left at
the moment.
Which of these looks fun that we don't
have and isn't too hard to implement?
maybe river raid.
You basically just pick an end that
looks like it would be cool and it
doesn't and that if you like just do a
basic a little bit of research is not
going to be insanely difficult to uh
implement.
it's better to do a project that you can
like fully complete and do very well
rather than doing something that's too
big that you can only sort of like 80%
finish.
This is good.
It's a nice policy.
Very nice policy.
Bet you would added a bunch of extra
stuff.
Recommend the end goal to be like as an
exercise how to wrap it up.
You want to have a stable, fast
environment that you can train a
reasonable agent on and that you can PR,
right? Like ideally it's human playable
with like the standalone demo. You can
PR it. You can put it on the website
with your agent.
Code is like reasonably clean. You know,
I'm not going to be like crosseyed
looking through the code. We have lots
of nice examples of that.
from X. Ah, yeah. Yeah. Okay. Light.
All right.
Um,
and I do merge in. Sometimes it takes me
a while to go through a big batch of PRs
because I have all this stuff to do.
But be good.
I wanted to look at right the
buffer.
Oh yeah, it totally refactored my entire
thing.
Does PR have value if I don't expect it
to be merged? It depends. Sometimes I
pull stuff out of PRs without merging
them, but that's more for like core
infrastructure and like performance
stuff. Um, for environments, typically
it has value if like you're let's say
that you're like you're relatively new
low-level dev and you just want me to
take a quick look at something so that
you can get some feedback and then start
on a more complex project that you do
expect to be merged. That's typically
the way it goes.
I'm generally pretty generous with my
time for people who are at least trying
though.
You know, like I get annoyed when people
make mistakes that are very clearly
outlined. Like, you know, I gave you two
pages to read. It says do it this, this,
and this. And you clearly just did not
pay attention to that. But, I mean, if
you're just like generally doing stuff
and making mistakes that are sensible
that you would expect from a new
programmer or a new low-level dev or new
to RL, like that's all fine.
Like I get annoyed for instance when
people submit me like super abstracted
crap where like you know they've made
like four levels of nested function
calls where they just need one right
because like that took conscious effort
on your part. that's not the default
thing. You know,
there are lots and lots of things you
can take from uh
the examples and guides though.
convert. Make sure that whatever you're
doing, there's like a reasonable way to
represent ops and action spaces. That's
a big killer for more complex projects
is like, you know, doesn't run without
huge fancy encoder that we don't know
how to make fast.
Those are more good for like scale up
target projects
than they are for uh baseline ends.
Yeah, but like just getting state is not
enough because if state is a bunch of
sets for instance, then we need this
entity encoder which is what I'm working
on now. If it has like 2D data, do we
need comms? Can we just put it in flat?
Right.
Next big RL algo improvement that truly
generalizes
um setable simulator state. Actually, we
were working on that a couple weeks ago
in research, but priorities had to get
shifted around for a a client. So, we're
basically just going to swap some of the
stuff that was going to go into puffer
six is now going to go into puffer 5,
and some of the stuff that was going to
go into puffer five is going to go into
six.
Progress is still being made though.
Either way.
giving the agent. No, we already have
memory.
Simulator state is different. So
simulator state is basically letting an
agent to jump to any portion of the end
of it has seen before
in order to be able to practice things
that is that are still difficult for it
or to refine skills.
faster architecture
most likely, Jess.
It would just take some work.
Like
the thing is, it's not even clear to me
that comms are the right architecture
for something like chess at all. you
know, most of the things we're not
actually doing pixels most of the time.
Um, coms are probably the correct
architecture there on VIT and there's
just not really a good way to do that
super fast.
You really don't need to separate blocks
of the net out like that.
The pro there are problems in that
space, but not exactly the ones you're
describing.
Um,
chess architecture. I really don't just
I would expect that the um like the
architectures from supervised should be
reasonable. There should already be lit
in that space. And then you basically
just have to go through and bring it
down to what is in the lip that it can
also be made fast.
Okay. So, this is basically what we
expect. The new architecture works, but
we need to uh we need some speed ups.
Also, I'm use rat real quick. I'll be
back in a couple minutes.
Transformer sparse encodings.
Okay, so
that's unfortunate. I'll be right back,
guys. Sorry to pop on GitHub if you
haven't already, by the way. It's free.
It helps me out a lot.
Oops. Screen. There we are.
Okay.
back.
This is random throwaway test, so we
don't really have to care.
And let me do one thing on the side
Here.
Basic profile.
Cool.
So, what we're basically going to do
here,
um,
we're just going to like on the real
end, this is a real end, right? We're
just going to kind of go in a loop and
see if we can optimize a little bit.
It's just the mat moles, I'm pretty
sure. Uh, I guess I should probably
compute
memory pressure.
What would the memory pressure of that
be? It's a bigger network for sure. Um,
without this I maybe the memory pressure
is a little bit higher.
Do obs to
16 dims.
So it's four each to eight. So it's like
double maybe.
Now, that's like an ideal use case, I
think.
And arguably, um, anytime where the OBS
dim is
greater than 16,
you should save bandwidth.
Where is this block for? Emmy block.
Where the hell's this kid called?
Oh, wra. See,
It's very frustrating in some sense
because they should just be fused. We
literally just want to fuse a max with
the output of the uh the mat mole.
This should still be small, shouldn't
it?
how you came to your color scheme. I uh
this is my own config.
I know. I I made it one Okay.
Oh, hang on. Wait, wait. This gives us a
clue.
You would think that this should have to
just exist somewhere.
presumably we just have a crappy
backwards kernel somewhere.
Am I missing something? Does anybody
know? Am I missing something? Like,
do you need to store activations for
backwards
that are bigger than I think? No, you
don't. Right. There's nothing big that
you have to materialize that I'm not
thinking of.
Yeah. Yeah, that would be skipping the
layer.
Okay,
I do want to be doing something better
than just saying, "Oh, make it faster."
Um,
I think I've looked all over for this
already, though. Like, you know, used
mat
See, the very annoying thing, and this
is why I hate having to do um this
specific type of fusion,
like the vast majority of the complexity
here.
There you go.
The vast majority of the complexity just
comes from having to match the mat
moles.
So I think then the interpretation of
this is that the research was correct
but I only modeled the forward pass and
then this thing just wrote a shitty
backwards kernel.
optimize
kernel time.
So the key with this architecture right
is
I guess maybe in the meantime we should
compute the traffic. So
let's say that we do
we do like 8* 16 input that gets you to
128, right? So if you have um if you
have 16 things with eight dimensions
each let's say
or eight things with 16 eight things
with 16 dimensions each
is nice. So with eight things with 16
dimensions each,
then that goes
it's the same, right? So eight things
with 16 you project to 16
which is 128 bytes mem bandwidth.
when does this become unfavorable?
I think this trade-off just becomes
unfavorable when the um
the entities are smaller than 16 each in
the original obs.
That's all.
Yeah, that's that's got to be it
obviously.
So, when you have a ton of very small
entities,
this gets to be somewhat unfavorable.
But for any like reasonable end where
you at least have a few different things
than the obs,
the architecture should be relatively
reasonable.
It added biases. So now it has the
shitty bias kernels as well.
I actually don't know whether this will
mess up anything in the arch.
Lots of little tiny kernels like that
can very easily screw up uh training. It
slipped those in because that wasn't in
the original architecture.
How do you know when you can get away
with removing biases? You don't. You
just do it and see if everything [ __ ]
fails.
It's very possible we might be able to
do better with biases and I'm kind of
just trolling, but soda is soda.
Right. But like you can write custom
kernels that are better optimized for
small ops. Right.
biases cuts forward backwards by another
little chunk.
Yep. Look at that.
Plus nearly 10% PF from removing the
stupid biases in just the small encoder
layer. Closing the gap.
Dude, most of the time it's just
overhead. Like
I guess one interpreta. So I guess there
is one interpretation of your thing that
like makes sense which is
you probably there's a major
inefficiency I would assume here. I
don't know if it can do some intelligent
packing but because the tensor cores are
probably bigger than the matmo we're
doing here.
There's a lot that can be optimized.
Look, like yes, it probably is very hard
to hit like peak flops or whatever, but
the thing is your standard
implementation is so so so far off
efficient anyways that realistically we
can at least get it down to something
reasonable just with some relatively
simple optimizations.
Oh, and yeah, this also still works by
the way. You can see this is the same uh
score 84. So, the biases didn't do [ __ ]
You really just need the entity
structure is
idealistic max perf. Yeah, but the thing
is like dude, everything is so so so far
off max PF for small networks. Like
that's not the question. Like the
question is not can we get like 100%
MFU.
Um, the question is, can we get some
nets that run a few mill SPS
with like these tiny little models,
which should be a lot easier. Earth.
I I have to just admit here that I don't
particularly know what I'm doing on this
section. Um,
this is kind of annoying because like
realistically I shouldn't be doing any
of this [ __ ] I should just be using the
Kublast mat mole with a max fused in. I
can't do that because the Kublast mat
mole is an open source. I'm sure they
have lots of different paths for
different size
uh different size operations,
but there's just no way for me to get
access to that.
Ah, okay. Hang on. Hang on. We can do
something with this.
I think I can do
let me projection re. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Hang on. We can do something with
this.
Can you fuse the re with the input to
the next kernel? You can, right?
Okay. I actually that's something I can
try
This is I need less [ __ ] AI on the
timeline and more of this.
This is good.
It's funny that it actually didn't even
come up with the obvious optimization
at all on its own. Kind of embarrassing,
isn't it?
It didn't even think of just using a
couplass mat for the first layer.
Okay,
let's see. Is this any good?
We match the compute unit as well. Maybe
B float
or actually I think Bflat only was make
a
difference with tensor course probably.
Can you solve
threesome in linear time?
What
you asking me? Le code.
Don't do that, man.
Okay, revert this. And then I This thing
is dumb. Let's just give it the obvious
change.
So, I I don't know why it decided to use
a um
I really don't know why
it decided that it wanted to use a
custom kernel for both of these things.
It really should just have a custom
kernel for the second layer. Like look
at this mess that it makes.
It's very stupid
because it hit Yeah. Right here. So
linear max this is good but look why did
it write this you don't need this right
No, it's not that it's labbotomized.
These models are just not very they're
really really dumb in ways that don't
make any sense.
like they've seen every possible version
of you know matmo plus op kernel
but then like I don't know how it
doesn't occur to you right if you have a
if you have a kernel like this is so
easy right if you have an operation that
is linear relu linear pointwise max
right the key is that you need to fuse
the pointwise max that's the slow op I
don't know why you would also then go
write a kernel
or the first linear op. Just call K
blast. What's wrong with you?
Like yes, actually matching the
pointwise max um like the Matt mold to
pointwise max kernel. That's actually
kind of annoying because you need to
match KU blast at least for your
specific case.
And that's actually tough. Um,
but calling coup blast is not hard.
I mean, the thing is like the very like
that's such an obvious thing to test.
I don't think you do add an activation
buffer.
I'm not missing something here, I'm
pretty sure. Right. So, this is
Shouldn't be doing this anyways. This is
completely stupid.
We actually don't want it to do this
because this couples us to um this
couples us to the single
format here.
So that's actually good that this
optimization is gone. We want this to be
a a loop.
I don't know. Viber, we just call that
being stupid.
Okay, I guess this is just the Yeah,
it's just trying to count flops for the
profile corn. It's fine.
Hollow Plateau. Going to get first Sim
quiver. Yeah.
Well, we've gotten some uh Finn's doing
some cool stuff on Net Hack as well,
Valo. And uh we also have a collab now
with Craft Hack. So, I think we're going
to have a lot of fancy ends pretty soon.
It would be awesome to have some nice
demos with Colo as well.
Inferno is like the Inferno plus Colo,
the NH demo. I mean, this is all just
going to be great. Also, the Entity
Encoder. I don't know if you're still
using it, but um
I'm optimizing the Entity Encoder stuff
now.
It definitely can be made fast.
It's slightly non-trivial.
Obviously, these models make a mess of
everything.
I think there's only one like one pretty
non-trivial up.
was a straight up gain. All right, so
I'll point you to this branch when I
finish this, man. You're probably going
to want to integrate some changes
because
the kernel actually needs to be written
correctly or it's super slow.
Yeah. And then it'll just have one set
of kernels to iterate on which will be
good.
Oh, yay.
I didn't realize this.
Uh, okay. The grat actually that works
nice
and it's weight gradient. Yep.
Cool. So, that's what we wanted, right?
We didn't want to have a big pile of
kernels. We just needed the custom max,
like pointwise max up.
Um, I explained this earlier, but to
anybody who just joined.
So, this op, it's basically
it's like you have a bunch of different
entities in a scene, right? So, say this
fish is your agent and it can observe
other fish around it and maybe some
other targets.
This happens in a lot of ends just where
you have a thing and then you have a
bunch of other things and the ordering
doesn't really matter. It's sort of like
a a set of observations so to speak.
There are two ways you can represent
this. One is you can just concat
everything into a flat vector. The
problem is that this doesn't capture
order invariance. So like it's a totally
different obs if I switch the order of
this one and this one. Um that's a
really bad property to have. The other
thing you can do is you can build some
sort of entity representation where like
you concat your embedding or your
features with the features of every
other agent. So it's like me and agent
one, me and agent two, me and agent
three, so on so on and so forth. You put
this into an embedding layer. So each of
these gets embedded separately
and then you need to do a maximum over
the entities. The problem with this is
this applies massive memory pressure
because you get the embedding dimension
for every single entity instead of just
once per OBS. So the trick is that you
send it through a lowdimensional
bottleneck. So you only have a
16dimensional encoding per entity with a
relu and then you project the 16 dim
back up to 128 and you fuse a max
operation. If you do this you get the
memory pressure of 16 times the number
of entities but you don't get the memory
pressure of 128 times the number of
entities because of the fused max op.
And the reason you structure it like two
layers this way instead of one layer is
you really need this second layer to
have any sort of representational
capacity. We have tested this
extensively. You need need need two
layers and um 16dimensional per entity
doesn't hurt the representation because
that's enough features for one entity
encoding but you need a bigger
representation for the whole
observations. So this architecture plays
very nicely. The problem is this fused
linear plus max op doesn't exist like
this is not a common op that you just
have a kernel for unfortunately. So we
have to write one and whenever you have
to write a kernel that involves a matmo
you're immediately up against um Kublas
right the super super optimized Nvidia
kernels for comparison which makes
things really obnoxious like you can't
just fuse a max onto their existing
Imple.
So that's the quick version of what I'm
doing at the moment. Um this all this
garbage is me just like iterate on
Like in a sense I'm just trying to have
it iterate on matching close enough to
kublas matmo for this one specific case.
Um this should not be the hard part
right the hard part is this architecture
and knowing that this architecture works
like the first layer you can literally
just call kublass. So you just need like
matt mole max
and then it's basically just whatever
the hell tricks this thing has to
iterate on for the mat mole this sort of
small shape
in order to get roughly close to uh
Kublas.
To be fair, anybody that has a better
CUDA background than I have could
probably do this quite easily. Um, I
just personally I don't know what would
be a good default way to do a mat from a
low dim to a like small but bigger dim
fused with a max. Like I don't know what
pattern you would use for your mat mole
if there's like a specific tiling
structure or some other optimization.
It need manual interventions. Of course
it's like this thing is incredibly
stupid.
I don't particularly care at the moment
for this because this is just like I
just need to see that it's possible to
get this thing to be fast on a real
problem. Um, and I'm sure I can get one
of my contributors who has more
experience on
optimizing like kernels with matt moles
in them
like kernel fusion with matt moles. I'm
sure we have a couple contributors that
can like figure out a better way to do
this. I kind of just need an initial
demo. I think I have the the initial
thing is correct. So the initial thing
is literally where is it
should be in here somewhere, but it's
just calling our pre-existing
blast wrapper.
This is good.
Wait, wait. This is good. Isn't this
good?
Yeah, it ought to make mistake making.
Oh, look at this. Look. 6.4 mil. 6.5.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is almost the
same speed as our original. So, I mean,
we take a little bit of a per hit, but
there we go. This is
way, way, way, way better than we had
before.
What's the config?
Total agents 812.
And I think this is actually
pretty small mini batch, right? Yeah,
pretty small mini batch. And Horizon.
Yeah, this is not an ideal config and
it's still decent.
That's pretty good overall.
I would say
Actually, I'm going to point Vo at this
as well because he'll have a use case
once this is done.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We don't need any of
this anymore. It's good.
Why is it It should be okay. Good. It's
still cutting it. It shouldn't be that
long.
Any idea where I should start? Depends
on your level of experience. Um, there's
a guide on my X if you are newer to RL,
sort of like a blog post style thing on
how to get into RL and how to start
building some ends and puffer and sort
of how to learn. If you're more
experienced and you're just looking for
puffer specifically, most new people
still find it useful to build at least
some sort of uh environment just because
um just because it get it sort of gets
you used to the project in a reasonable
way.
After that there's like depending on
your interest there's algo side stuff.
There is a ton a ton of infraside stuff.
There's like architecture work. Um
there's like just sort of moonshot very
hard M to solve as standalone projects.
I mean we kind of do a little bit of
everything at least within the realm of
like hyperf
higher sim plus RL.
Please tell me this.
Why is this so long, man?
Me grad.
Hang on. Let me see.
Materialize. Yeah. Okay. This thing just
is a mess basically.
Output grad kernel.
Brad entity kernel.
and a materialized kernel as well.
Okay, not ideal
Honestly, I wouldn't mind somebody that
has decent colonel experience with uh
well, specifically with fusing [ __ ] with
Matt Moles.
Um,
I will commit this for now just so we
have something to point it at
9 mill SPS
and this to be clear you can't get this
score with the default architecture so
it does need this custom kernel
like that's super stable
I think we will just do get add
Boom. Okay, good. We win.
We win this. Cool. Now, let's just go
point Spencer at this.
If anybody wants to take a look at this
as well.
This is on the 5C branch.
CL. It's in 5C here. I'll put this link
in the chat real quick.
So, it's basically just the ME kernels.
It's just the fused linear.
It's a fused linear max op. It's linear
to pointwise max and then the grads for
it.
The key is you have to not materialize
and then you also have to match m uh
coup blast annoyingly.
I think that's basically it though. I
just wanted to do a short couple hour
stream on this. Um I think wait is it
100 p.m.? I think the thing I have to do
is at 100 p.m. Let me go double check to
see if I have time or not. I'll be right
back.
Yeah, I uh I got to get going, guys. Um,
thanks for tuning in. This is kind of
just like a one-off thing. We might have
to do a little bit more on this, but
this is enough for us to start testing
this in our application. Um, we
definitely want a cleaner kernel for
this. Faster kernel would be great as
well. We're still taking a little bit of
a per hit for this, though. I think the
extra layer makes that somewhat
expected. Um, well, if you want to
support my work for absolutely free, I
stream lots of research and dev right
here. Just check puffer.ai, star the
GitHub, feed the puffer, star helps us
out a lot. join us on Discord
and uh in order to get involved with the